[Music]
hey what up jakey news peeps our topic
today is about dating dating yeah and we
don't have a show name yet I'll call it
our love gloves gloves let it stick to
your hand
love your glove definitely use gloves
yeah only use clothes so like I've
always wondered what dating would be
like cuz I don't think I have that much
days we talk about you've been with
someone to be Nelson they're coming for
your job Julie I think a lot of you in
the comments would like to answer your
question oh by taking you out on a date
and you know you know what actually
sparked it was
I always remembering a conversation I
had with Ryan along to have a go cuz I
think Ryan was just entering into a
relationship and he'll kind of going
through like the roller coasters of what
it's like to be a relationship did you
do dating yeah for like it's like
college to probably solid like four or
five you tell me the difference in your
mind the definitions between dating and
relationship because I feel like we
still date even being in a relationship
I like going on dates I'm getting
hoarded like being courted yes according
to me knows that he's in yeah so there's
a difference where dating there's still
some fear there so you guys can go on
you guys go on dates but you're married
right so you're not dating you know the
feeling of being courted I think that's
impressive
we're each other dating you're recording
somebody but it's not established that
you're exclusive
yeah hmm but some people use dating as a
way a term for like work together
boyfriend growth yeah but Julia is
separating it is like going on dates
versus being in an active relationship
yeah
yeah those Julie you've never dated much
you go straight for the but that's why
but marriage tip always be courting
always be data that's definitely
important yeah why don't you be very
much Julia I don't know I think it's
just cause like in high school my high
was broken into like a moving all
[ __ ] now
that piece of [ __ ] good I didn't feel
like I was worthy of anyone fine
how did he break your heart and you're
still backward that's just how I was
feeling you're not and I just don't like
because I was feeling a certain way I
didn't want to project it on to some guy
that I was dating that's so nice
I just didn't date anyone until I felt
like I was ready I went through [ __ ] all
the girls face did you have a whole
phase no but I mean sometimes I kind of
wish but some days I'm like nah I'm
actually pretty good with out of the
whole phase you don't seem like a whole
lady people used to think I was
promiscuous yeah for sure cuz I really
like sex but that's not the same thing
right oh because I was serial monogamist
like I like having sex a lot with one
person she likes familiar dick yeah yeah
and I like doing different things with
familiar not 31 flavors dick yeah I'm
actually terrified of STDs oh yeah yeah
yeah that's is I also like like I'm
really picky about the guy like why are
you so picky because I have to really
make me laugh or I really like have good
conversations cuz you're whatever sexual
whatever could be a sexual appeal sexual
you make it sound like it's an active
thing what the years that you're still
this way I really like sex what do you
mean hold hands please what do you mean
I'm with a really funny guy who's
intellectually stimulating emphasize how
you have to be intellectually stimulated
but never physically that's true but I
she does thank you Joe you don't you
wonders to the chemistry makes it
physically simulating I I'm the same way
so for this particular topic well is
most curious about is what it's like to
see like multiple people or on the same
time because for me I feel like I'm only
the type of president when we like to
see one person at a time but like never
multiple it was the most miserable I've
ever been doing that well you're going
around really much fun doing most
miserable I've ever been past tense
I mean that just sounds so stressful to
like try to deal with like other people
oh well how much time are you spending I
don't know dude this is this is just all
something that I'm thinking about sewing
what I did was basically covering for
the fact that I wanted a relationship
but I was trying to act like I didn't so
I was juggling different favors the
first well I think there's this phase
right where first a lot of guys do this
where they kind of jump the gun and and
after they meet the girl once and then
go on a date they're already planning
the marriage that happens to a lot of
[ __ ] dudes yeah yeah that's true so I
went to I feel like guys are sometimes
more romantic yeah
actually do you think that tried to go
through a whole phase it up for like
when I was single for the only time I
was ever ever single and I was just
looking for one [ __ ] buddy I wasn't even
trying to dated multiple people at once
I just wanted one [ __ ] buddy that I feel
like you know during those times we're
just really like horny but you don't
want relationship so but then I would
give them the premise and then they
still want a relationship after had the
same thing I was with a girl who was
just like that I guess she was going
through her whole face at that time or
something once you get this dick though
and then when we assumed oh hey like so
rude together and she's like no and I
was like I was like for me I always
thought that like that was the next up
that that's not what you're supposed to
do and she was totally not for it and I
wasn't you sounds like what I don't
understand what are we what are we doing
right oh I laid the ground rules
beforehand they still no rules I had no
rules it was like baby I mean my not
being good enough no I wouldn't know
anything like that was just like I was
really like legitimately confused
because it's like wait then yeah this is
not how this equation works the girl I
have a friend I was like man she'll give
me head but she doesn't want a
relationship with me I don't understand
what's going on yeah am I not good
enough and I'm like yeah that's all
missing something she's only using me to
suck my dick yeah it's like what that's
crazy I think 500 days of summer is
legit because of how he like put that in
his brain up they were like this perfect
soul mate thing but then she's really
like not into it cuz I was like yeah
that's kind of them if we were saying
like oh she's such a [ __ ] and then I'm
like nah like it was really his fault
for doing all that cuz I've been putting
on that pedestal cuz Mike I've seen
myself do that too and being like ah
like I [ __ ] [ __ ] up because I like and
she clearly communique
that throughout the movie she was like I
don't wanna be I don't want to be a
thing I don't want it to be a thing and
he kept trying to push it on her do that
buddy yeah that's a lesson something we
learned the hard way though
like I feel cuz it's kind of hard to
well for some people I know myself
included I've done that like maybe once
or twice where I was sort of like after
a couple dates or whatever like oh this
is going well and then it would kind of
like all come apart and they'll like
towards one of course towards the end of
it but I think for me the hardest part
with dating was initially having you
know having those first couple dates go
well and then it not working out and
then having that kind of like ending
point and being like and being okay with
it ending and then having to like kind
of sit with yourself and just be like oh
I guess that didn't work so you have
definitive endings or for me it's always
just like petered out I had a couple
things that were no that didn't have a
definitive thing and that pissed me off
even more because I was kind of like
what the [ __ ] like what the that was
when I first started dating I was like I
don't know what the [ __ ] is going on and
no one's really explaining anything to
me so I had no frame of reference to
like what was it was it you ghosting her
she goes think you should go see me yeah
thank you being like what okay
at least no I play no and then but I did
have a couple girls that were like yeah
I'm just not interested and I like that
way bored because I was like all right
cool and you know it's kind of like all
passions to kill me when people would
tell you that not interested is the
being led on yeah yeah and I back then I
was like really frustrating I'm like how
come girls just can't be straight up and
then I saw how other guys would react
yeah totally I need no wonder girls are
beyond is it because guys will be like
you could be honest with me you could be
honest and then they'll get the truth
and they'll be like will [ __ ] you [ __ ]
or [ __ ] I don't react like that and
I've never been liable [ __ ] you right
like I've never acted yeah neither have
I somebody there's some crazy [ __ ]
out there that snaps Lena and then I had
some my girlfriends I can explain it to
man I'm like oh that is really scary
like it's really scary
they even if you just don't want to give
them your number yes and then I was like
I I kind of get it now but without that
context like me just kind of being there
like Oh what the [ __ ] like just kind of
just came to an end like what that yeah
I find that that reaction comes from the
people who feel like they're the nice
person yeah nice oh my god nice guys are
the [ __ ] word
I [ __ ] hate [ __ ] the perception of
nice guys ya know I have [ __ ] hate
people versus oh I'm a I'm a nice guy
I'm a nice guy owner sad like you know
like nice guys when we finish last oh
wait [ __ ] you do it you have every
single [ __ ] control to change that
outcome
well sometimes girls aren't really clear
with you either right so so I remember I
was seeing this girl and then all of a
sudden she stopped texting me and so to
help her understand how I felt I was
like your [ __ ] your [ __ ] text her
that every single night yeah to help her
understand who she really liked and when
she blocked you that you're graduating I
thought it was a real story or as I was
like wait what I just made that just
maybe the epiphany for someone who
friendzone me I realized that she might
have thought that I would like outbursts
or something like that but like I didn't
like you were saying like I've never
like done that yeah get that feeling
from you exactly so that's why but it
was a person who was very nice she was a
very nice person so I think she just
didn't like let me down because we were
basically dating like I was holding her
hand and we were like gonna do the other
movie that's different so then I was
like so when I like brought notion up I
was like she was like I don't hold hands
if I just want to [ __ ] you well there
are so where's the handling cuz we
didn't times I'm like that's usually the
indicator like at least my previous you
know relationships of girls hand-holding
is going to lead to some [ __ ] yeah yeah
but there are people who are like
they'll be into you and they're like
going back with their ex and they're not
letting you know that did that very
possible she helped my dick why won't
you hold my hand
didn't get that far you get that good
love song she sucked my dick and then
said I don't want to be with you I don't
want to kiss you then I kind of just
want to elaborate just a little bit on
the whole nice guy thing or a nice girl
right it's just that don't feel entitled
to someone speak yeah yeah that's the
thing that really bugs me and the only
guy that's ever cussed me out it was a
nice guy and he cussed me out while
being like you're gonna go back to your
shitty ex-boyfriend [ __ ] you you're so
[ __ ] stupid you're the [ __ ]
stupidest person I've ever known I was
like I'm trying to cut deer yeah Lorna's
Gary see why you [ __ ] [ __ ] ass [ __ ]
you can't recognize brick
your bowl my god so your psychoanalyzing
me and saying that you're a nice guy and
that I'm a [ __ ] and that I'm stupid
cuckoo cuckoo cuckoo and this is a guy
when I told him beforehand like I just
want sex I don't want I don't want
anything have it just so you know he's
like I don't know I'm gonna treat you
right I'm like no no no you're not gonna
treat me right after like it's not we're
just gonna be friends and he was like
got it got it got it and I I do feel
like it is very difficult in the dating
game too because you don't know how
honest they're being everyone's kind of
like preparing your best day want you to
know yeah yeah we're like pretending and
um yeah I mean especially now cuz I'm
single again and like I'm just thinking
about oh how would things work now that
I'm women in their 30s I'm Way more
straight forward that's what I've heard
my buddy he was when he was like in his
30s he had dated like this 50 year old
woman like they're both marshallers so
she's like a fit not like a old like you
might oh my gosh she's 50 she's hitting
she was martial artists in Taekwondo or
something like that
besides like that was his the best
relationship ever
because in bed she said exactly what she
wanted what he wanted to do like when
they went out of date it was very
forward understatement
yeah it wasn't like a beat around the
bush kind of a thing he's like yeah that
was like the best like most straight boy
I should go for a fifty-year-old
you should try a thrower back up you
know Jennifer Aniston's in her 50s like
Jen Hansen's got a going on now I do
feel a calmer energy just now like then
you know there's like that young man
energy where you're just like oh I don't
know she likes me or not now I don't
care now I'm like it's it's a totally
different level of confidence where it's
like you know I've talked and it's like
oh she's not into me okay
I want it reciprocated right but then
when you're younger you wanna conquer
you wanna be everybody that person
doesn't like you yeah you wanna you know
it just had less going on to be honest
like I just had more I just had more
time to invest into like you know dating
and like adhering no sucks so bad when
you're in your 20s and [ __ ] and like I
think like yeah it's it's totally
different now for me well it's important
to for the woman to understand how you
feel like even like I remembered getting
rejected by this girl and then I showed
up at her house and I was crying
and I and I said I just wanted you to
see how much I cared about and I cried
over girl in middle school would you do
that and then I sent her pictures also
me crying at different times you have to
heighten is so that people know oh my
god oh my god a girl who broke up with
me was crying my she was you sent her a
horse head I did not but I send her me
crying um while I was watching The
Godfather at least he didn't like take
his ear off and like send that to her
and I was like I'm not crying about the
movie that would have been if you took
your off you would have really known
that you would she loved you thanks good
than that whole thing just you know I
heard a guy did it once and works out
for him yeah pretty well yours are real
romantic
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]